For a very important part of
this legislature, we have been denouncing the
paralysis of Europe, alerted by the
rise of populism concerned
about major crises such as the refugee crisis,
and I believe that it is time to
be brave and to understand that
fundamental reforms are necessary for
the union  because we need a
reform of the eurozone that focuses on
achieving economic and
social convergence and that translates into
fair and equal growth because we
need a social pillar like
the European social democrats have been defending
that guarantees the rights
of workers that guarantee
decent wages and fair pensions
because we need a
strong community budget that can tackle new
policies such as defense and
cooperation but that does not allow cuts
in fundamental policies such as
cohesion and agriculture and I would like to
point out one issue, the
three institutions are here  the three men who  The EU presides over
the European institutions, the
Parliament, the Council and the Commission have
established the priorities for 2018,
forgetting gender equality policies,
the fight against
the wage gap is not a priority
, gender-based violence is not a priority,
conciliation is forgotten  very
worrying because we leave aside
half of the European voices half of
the European weapons half of the
European hearts we women will
be here to remember it and to be the
voice of your consciences